Buenos días el objetivo es muy amplio en
realidad es que los países desarrollados
y concretamente el presidente Manuel
macron que tuvo la idea de esta Cumbre
el año pasado durante la cop en Egipto
se han dado cuenta de que el sistema
financiero heredado de bretton woods de
1944 está obsoleto sobre todo para
muchos países que ni siquiera existían
cuando ese orden mundial del Banco
Mundial del fondo monetario
internacional y las bancas regionales se
creó por lo mismo hay que hacer llegar
el dinero dice el presidente Manuel
macron a los países pobres sobre todo
enfrentado a la crisis climática dice él
no puede ser que los países pobres
tengan que elegir entre atender o la
pobreza o el cambio climático y para eso
hay que facilitar justamente ese flujo
de capitales hacer que no sea tan
difícil para los países endeudarse y
sobre todo dice él Llamar la inversión
privada garantizar a los inversores
privados que sus inversiones En
transición climática los países pobres
no van a ser muy arriesgadas así que es
una cosa muy compleja que va a tomar dos
días aquí en París hay que decir que la
iniciativa real en todo caso viene de la
primera ministra de Barbados que tuvo
esta idea justamente porque su Isla es
muy muy vulnerable al cambio climático y
sin embargo son países que contribuyen
muy poco recordemos que de las víctimas
directas del cambio climático las más
afectadas un noventa y siete por ciento
se encuentran en países pobres el cambio
climático el covid y la guerra en
Ucrania justamente están pasando una
factura muy alta a los países más pobres
bueno esta fue una inauguración a cargo
del presidente Manuel cuál fue su
principal mensaje
Sí el principal mensaje del presidente
Manuel macron es que él confía no cierto
en el mercado pero hubo otras personas
que también participaron en esta
inauguración como la primera ministra de
barbado mía ella por ejemplo recordó
justamente que en estos momentos hay una
tormenta tropical que está afectando a
su Isla ella dudó en venir Sin embargo
dijo tengo que estar aquí para pasar el
mensaje no podemos seguir conversando
tenemos que hacer una reforma una
verdadera transformación de este sistema
monetario internacional también habló el
presidente de níger un país que está en
África en medio de grandes países con
conflictos con violencia recordó que en
su país hay una gran sequía pérdida de
la diversidad y que justamente eso
engendra violencia y migraciones y
calculo que de aquí al año 50 por
ejemplo en su país va a haber 70
millones de habitantes dijo necesito
dinero para educar a las mujeres para
que no se casen a partir de los 18 años
como lo hace un 70 por ciento de las
mujeres en ese país se puedan educar y
salir de la crisis y también habló
Antonio Gutiérrez el secretario general
de la ONU dijo algo muy interesante
justamente que este sistema de bretton
woods por ejemplo permite unos fondos
que se llaman de tiraje o fondos
especiales que dan instituciones como el
fondo monetario internacional pues tras
el covid los países desarrollados se
llevaron un 70% esos puntos porque el
sistema está hecho así no es algo ilegal
digamos o que esté fuera de las reglas
sin embargo el sistema está pensado en
los países desarrollados por último le
pregunto que otros discursos se destacan
y que siguen la agenda
sí Bueno hay que decirles que el
presidente Pedro el presidente
colombiano está aquí es uno de los tres
latinoamericanos también está el
presidente de Brasil y el presidente
cubano él justamente trae todo una
propuesta hoy salió una editorial suya
en el diario lomonte él propone un Plan
Marshall para los países pobres
básicamente que estas entidades
financieras entreguen dinero a cambio de
acción climática en estos países me
gustó mucho su enfoque es muy distinto
del del presidente macron él dijo Yo no
creo en el mercado pero tampoco tenemos
tiempo para ir contra el mercado así que
me parece que esta es una buena
iniciativa que es un buen compromiso por
decirlo para que vencemos dice porque
está nuestra especie en juego